Hollywood's so unoriginal now like I
[__] hate it really I hate it like I
watched the Barbie movie right yeah we
saw the Barbie movie and [__] the
[__] was crazy like I was excited for it
I was like bro this is gonna be cool
like you know like yeah you know I know
I'm not a girl or Nothing But like I
could see the importance for girls you
know because they grew up with it sure
so I was like you know what let me go
watch this out bro oh my gosh the moral
of the movie is men deserve no rights no
they deserve a little bit all right no
one of the kittens at the end said can
we at least get one seat in the House of
Representatives and she was like no no
no no she was like maybe you could be a
janitor and work your way up but so this
is the part of the movie I thought they
ended up getting some seats or whatever
no the part of the movie is Barbie land
the women run everything yeah and then
the kids they don't even have a house
they're just they're just there then Ken
and Barbie go into the real world and
then like Ken's like brainwashed to see
how the real world is and how like men
run everything patriarchy yeah infects
Barbie land and so he comes back yeah
and then when he comes back they're like
serving all the Ken's beers and like
it's just like a man Topia and Barbie's
like no this can't be it has to be
Barbie land it has to be Barbie land so
they emotionally manipulate every single
kin
and they make them fight each other you
know how your girl like she's mad at you
she'll emotionally manipulate you maybe
by like brushing your friend's arm and
you'll instead of pressing her you'll
press your friend like bro what the [__]
never happened
okay yeah yeah and they have all the
kids fight and while they're fighting
the Barbies take back over and then the
kids are like hey we just want a little
bit of power and all the Barbies are
like [__] now and then Barbie gets a
[__] at the end oh she goes to the gyno
yeah oh you've seen it I just heard it
damn I heard it because I went I saw
Oppenheimer really yeah
that's not gonna change it to me like
because for me it's not like how
colorful is it it's like it's a story
and I thought the story
I thought there were a couple things
that were done unbelievably well really
which were when the bomb I'm not ruining
anything because you know what the [__]
happens but when the bomb explodes
people are celebrating and
they Nolan makes you feel so eerie
like you're celebrating but it's the
death of all these people who aren't
even fighting you it's not like you're
bombing a military base it's innocent
people the war was kind of already won
it's more of a show of strength yeah
because they didn't even have to drop it
so it's like because they wanted to drop
it on the Nazis I think will they yeah
but the Nazi's already given up yeah and
the Japanese were still fighting now
also the Japanese did the Pearl Harbor
like so it's like I'll ask for it you
slap someone you you know what I mean
you won't get slapped and sometimes
someone got a bigger [__] fists right
but there is an argument to say that
didn't need to happen it's a military
base versus a whole town
yeah because we need to show we have
more than one in case anybody else won
so they but they go over there I think
but they he evokes this feeling it'd be
very easy for Nolan to just evoke this
feeling of we did it America is going to
pay him back we got it but instead it's
this feeling of why are they cheering
what's going on here yeah what's
happening and Oppenheimer is a piece of
[__] yeah and he shows that in the movie
but also may have been wronged so it's
like the movie isn't do they make the
bomb it's does he get Justice or do they
frame him and make him look like uh uh
just a piece of a garbage like a
treasonous like ambiguous they had a
whole thing and there's not one good
character in the whole movie which is
really interesting
Josh Peck only has a couple lines and I
you don't even know damn yeah yeah but
like switching up on America bro
no I mean what's I thought I I wanted to
go in there on somebody he wasn't Pro
America enough
um you gotta watch Top Gun again yeah
just to get back into it yeah yeah I
like but no I thought it was I thought
it was yeah I thought it was good I mean
like I'm the biggest Christopher Nolan
fan in the [__] world like I'm like I
think he loves The Dark Knight yeah like
golf they're amazing I think he's the
greatest filmmaker alive now really and
I I thought this was solid but I was
going in there going You're Gonna Give
me The Batman Trilogy now
yeah yeah I wish you did Barbie yeah
Barbie first because it would have
opened up your mind more I will say this
about the Barbie movie what what it's
done brilliantly in terms of the
marketing is that like it's it's become
a cultural moment in in the way that
like a Star Wars movie is where like
people get dressed up for Star Wars they
dress up people are going to the movie
theater they're in their outfits like
and you have to think about that when
you're creating content or you're
creating TV shows or films it's like how
can people wrap their identity around
this and how can they make this more of
just a sitting back experience how can
they turn this into their night yeah
something for them yeah
yeah so it's an IG moment and a film
yeah like and they just did that so well
and I was in the movie theater and let
me tell you something it felt like and
it was sold the Oppenheimer sold out it
felt like everybody in the theater was
there and I was on 14th a big movie
theater it felt like everybody there was
there to see me damn near doubled up
Oppenheimer box up it was like 130 to
80. yeah that makes yeah but they're
also smart with the marketing because
like they didn't they didn't make it
look like it was like they really they
really tried you when you went in there
oh yeah loudly down like because if I
would have seen how it was I probably
still would have seen it but I know
there would have been a way more
backlash because I seen like a bunch of
guys get behind it like guys have been
saying I'ma watch Barbie for the
insightful thought and foresight at my
watch Oppenheimer for the lasting
Giggles like dudes are like talking
about oh yeah I'm gonna go see Barbie
I'm gonna go see Barbie but like if it
was marketed like the movie was
but the guys wouldn't want to go see it
yeah women are about it apparently that
America Ferreira speech in it is really
good where like she describes what it's
like to be a woman I guess that's how it
is too it's like you know I'm not a
woman so yeah I can't get it the Rotten
Tomatoes expecting critic score to be
high and fan score to be a low just
based on what I was hearing but it was
90 and 90. but look uh but look at it if
you go back and look the the audience
score they're all verified
hmm what does that mean so they turned
off
verified people so it's only people who
are in Hollywood but like uh does that
mean blue check verify yeah yeah yeah
yeah so the uh the audience score is
only verified people so it's not an
authentication
uh no she don't like it oh really my
wife saw it she thought it was okay her
friend liked it though like it's kind of
it's crazy but like can the funniest
part of like he was the best part of the
movie no Gosling's hilarious he's so
good but he let's go boys let's go boy
you still need it
it was it was actually a surprise
comic relief I did not know he was that
funny that dude was hilarious does he
bust cheeks at the end bro he was trying
to hit so hard he really was like him
like he was low-key going down side
that's why she got the [__] probably so
he could oh yeah no she left him in I
don't wanna spoil it but you could spoil
it's fine I'm gonna get bombarded I was
gonna [__] take my family to see it
watch the Andrew Schultz podcast then go
to movie night that's the one thing I
kept thinking these conservatives were
getting so up and arms I was like yo
this is the gayest [__] to be offended
by is you didn't like Barbie yeah that's
like
Barbie's welcome bro that's embarrassing
that you're this upset about Barbie not
meeting your expectations yeah but I
guess they're just like yo if I'm taking
my kids go see this movie and my
daughter leaves being like yeah guys do
suck like if that is what the outcome is
oh yeah you feel this led that's that's
I imagine they're going to be like oh my
kids are gonna love this and then
there's like [__] jokes and they're
like what the [__] yeah no it was
definitely not a kid's movie yeah but
then again also it was more adults in
there
because I feel like girls today aren't
really playing with boys I thought it
was marketed to adults because kids
don't play with Barbie yeah I thought
that too but then I was told that like
they do still play with Barbie because
part of it I I yeah it's like still
cultural that's the other thing like you
tap into like 60 years of nostalgia yeah
it's if you you can't go wrong yeah
exactly it's like [__] Super Mario
Brothers movie like you have 60 years
no I heard it's really good though I
heard it's amazing I love it where it's
that good
I think some of the best Cinema like
really it's real Shifty said that too he
was like it was exceptional did you
watch it I did but I fell asleep so damn
but was that on some like you were tired
yeah life [__] okay yeah no you're gonna
re-watch it like I still like the first
one more because like I can just
re-watch that one it's like looking like
my comfort movie yeah but um I've been
doing reviews sometimes on my uh second
Channel yeah like when I see a movie
I'll just like hop on and just yeah tell
people watch Oppenheimer yeah I mean
you're a fan of History so like I think
that it'd be interesting for you to look
at it this is a couple things that like
see I don't think you would like it the
way you like history too I I was really
excited for it I just and I thought it
was an interesting choice to make there
not be one single good person in the
movie yeah but that's what happens when
the movie is about people who are making
nuclear weapons and Generals and
politicians none of them are good people
right and it's like sometimes people
aren't that good have to do a thing
that's not that good and that propels
the world into a direction that they
believe might be the best place to go
you might need to be not that good to do
that yeah but like Oppenheimer just felt
like just a complete [__] egomaniac
piece of [__] and like and the whole big
thing is at the end they're like trying
to like discredit him like call him a
communist or whatever like that not even
the end but like that's part of like the
Saga and it was done by a politician
trying to like distance himself from the
guy whatever and uh
but I'm also like yo Oppenheimer you got
to be smarter than that like why are you
hanging out with these commies like you
know you're building a [__] nuke like
you you can't be getting a side [__]
from communist [__] while you're
building a nuke while we're kind of
connecting with Russia but you know what
I mean it must be something about that
communist [__] because all our they
share with everybody yeah exactly yeah
someone someone Jamie look it up have
you been to Russia no no no no oh you
gotta do a prank over there bro oh yeah
yeah I'm not coming back yeah no but
Russian Russian chicks are
yeah they're good really I'll go on the
Russian bride
and I'll order one yeah this weekend was
a win for a Russian [__] because Barbie
was Russian [__] too
oh wait Margo Russian Australia
I thought she was Russian no no we said
she was a Russian six because we got
back from Russia and we were like these
are the most beautiful women ever but
Margot Robbie is an absolutely stunning
woman and anybody's saying she's mid on
the internet needs to shut the [__] up
except us